un escudo de defensa los aliados de La
otan fortalecen su presencia en el
flanco oeste de la alianza ante la
avanzada rusa en Ucrania
desde la perspectiva de seguridad la
otana acelerado las medidas para
garantizar la preparación de las fuerzas
aliadas y está trabajando en la mejor
consolidación a largo plazo de la
postura de disuasión y defensa del
flanco Oeste
dicho frente Está compuesto por los
países bálticos letonia lituania y
Estonia al mismo tiempo que los vecinos
ucranianos Polonia y Rumanía mientras
que Eslovaquia pidió el envío de tropas
de la otan a su territorio que aún debe
ser aprobado por el parlamento
específicamente Rumanía varios miembros
de la alianza ya enviaron refuerzos 500
soldados franceses 300 belgas y mil
estadounidenses se trasladaron a dicho
territorio así como 22 aviones para la
defensa de su espacio aéreo el objetivo
es compartido proteger cada centímetro
de los países de la otan por lo que la
alianza desplegó por primera vez sus
fuerzas de reacción rápida en contexto
de defensa colectiva
hoy en día la guerra es una realidad en
Ucrania está en las puertas de Rumanía
en las puertas de Europa de nuestra
Europa
estoy muy orgullosa de ver que hay
militares franceses hoy desplegados
junto a militares rumanos
estadounidenses belgas neerlandeses
italianos y alemanes en esta base bajo
la bandera de la otano
el martes en su discurso del estado de
La Unión El presidente estadounidense
Joe biden aseguró que no enviaría tropas
a Ucrania pero que respondería si Rusia
llegase a lanzar una avanzada hacia
occidente Rusia por su parte ha
arremetido contra la otan catalogando
sus intereses de expansionistas